I was hospitalized in section during I
was gnaws for I never believed there was
anything wrong with me and I thought I
knew anorexia was a thing but I didn't
think it was a thinking then I thought
you had to be like really skinny to have
a problem with eating more it was like
an obsession a constant thing in my head
I couldn't make myself look down the
street because I was like I'm gonna look
in every single shop window how I look
and I would see something completely
different I think to what what people
tell you to what I actually look like I
let it go on for longer because I was
kind of like no and there's nothing
wrong with me or complaining about
nothing you know you're not dangerously
ill similar what like I did we used two
drastic with and I was hospitalized the
section during I was nauseous I never
believed there was anything wrong with
me and I thought I knew anorexia was a
thing but I didn't think it was a thing
he meant websites it was all to do with
recovery stories of woven women books
what we know about recovery stories of
women and there was never really any men
and when I got hospitalized and into an
inpatient unit it was all women well it
was a bit of a chubby teen and I lost
weight I think that's what kicked off it
off for me
all I hadn't even said to come because
you look so good and I'm so conscious
like I'm 6 foot 2 I am a really tall
girl as people always point out to me
like I don't [ __ ] know but like so I
was I've always felt big cuz I've always
had like oh you're a big girl aren't you
from when I was little losing that
weight I was like ok this is me not I'm
a woman I'm becoming womanly like look
at me I'm gonna be like really skinny
and stuff it's such a dangerous line
between you know I lost the way and then
and then I just kept going
[Music]
- Oh Hospital and then went back into
college with all my friends you went to
school like a six for biggest
misconception for me was outgoing and
nobody want anything to do with me
because do for one that we schedule what
to say if the two they know where I've
been and for free you know I thought who
would want to associate with somebody's
mental in actual fact that Thursday I
went back you know I was like being back
at school before I got help everybody
just welcomed me with open arms but
nothing that was the biggest thing for
me was was going back into my group of
friends who knew me before I got ill but
also gonna know me after I got ill and I
didn't want them to think that but one
we don't want be friends of the other
two that I've changed as a person
I've just got different things what I
know after put up with wide enough
support with before the illness fought a
lot of strain on family relationships
like my sister was in the last year at
uni I was worried enough me being in
hospital is gonna put stress on her and
she's gonna fail a degree and then
that'll be all my fault my mom and dad
were arguing because they were both
worried and tensions gotten to worm and
I started questioned but I used to push
them away saying you'd be better off
without me I felt guilty that they were
changing their life for me my she's made
me when I was deep in like the throws of
them selfish my schedule was unmovable
like I would get like pissed off at
people kind of I was really hungry so
like I was a dick I was kind of bitter
I'd go on social media and just look at
pictures of people in there like bikinis
and go this is you know I'd [ __ ] hate
them
my sister was very woman and I think
that's what life help me
why have you just told me I've been
walking well to do that means I look far
and anyways I watched event because
we're all [ __ ] human that's what the
humans said yeah when they know they've
been ill I think it you do become like
the center of your household and you
know like my mom and dad definitely
roundabout like my dad saying the wrong
thing and then actually he hadn't really
said the wrong thing I just taken it the
wrong way do you not I mean that you're
kind of waiting for something to go
obviously the attention can be moved off
you and actually like even now I'm like
you never really said anything that
wrong like how could you say anything
right like the fact that you were there
is kind of the most important thing in
mental elfies to me more of a priority
is equal health there is something going
on in your head and you don't know what
it is just talk because there's no harm
in talking some days I thought I'm never
going to get there but in actual fact I
am wearing I'm nope because I got the
help and at the time I didn't want the
help or the are still places you can go
through bTW minute speak to a random or
not pause expect assessing for nothing
still viewing you as you it's really
important
[Music]
[Music]